have you ever gotten like food poisoning
and had to go on stage I should have
them on several stage or did you see
what I got oh my God it almost happened
at Staples Center and once in Germany I
said watch this Joey where are we at
when I [ __ ] on myself
no way
Norway mine was almost Germany almost
Staples Center so you had almost I I
want to make this very clear let me know
almost let me be clear there's no what I
did to these trash cans no no is is is
ungodly it I I don't know what I ate but
I was like I literally was like if I
don't walk off this stage right now I'm
going to [ __ ] myself in front of
thousands of people and that was pretty
traumatic I was sweating you [ __ ]
yourself on stage let me get a little
play-by-play here Kelly uh first of all
nobody shits themselves on purpose okay
uh did you trust a fart I'm a firm
believer I wasn't feeling well but The
Show Must Go On we're out the country I
don't have time to shut this show down
we got thousands of people I got 13 14
000 people out there I can't cancel this
show I'm not feeling good but I'm a
soldier through I go backstage before
the show I sit on the toilet for about
an hour and I just sit there please God
whatever has to come out let it all come
out now granted things came out I've had
my prayer I won't get too vulgar with it
yeah but I distribute it I distribute it
[Music]
get the knock on the door
Mr Hart they're ready for you are they
hear my security Kev it's time to roll
cool
stand up look myself in the mirror gotta
be honest I wasn't looking too good
I wasn't looking too good I saw it in my
face I'm just like I look weak whatever
but I'ma turn it on uh I get to to the
hallway walking to the stage I hear the
music and stuff at the place
hit me I'm not sweating I'm not sweating
I'm not I'm not a sick sweater it's it's
a feeling it's all within I'm all of it
lights hit Kelly I turn it on what's up
Norway what's going on I'm I'm in a
Groove Kelly I am killing my sickness is
a second thought it's not even a
priority
I get to my final seven minutes oh my my
final seven minutes I feel it
I say you got to be [ __ ] me that's
it I'm talking to myself I'm talking to
myself but at the same time I'm talking
to God and I don't argue with God but
this one we kind of had some words I'm
like you gotta be yeah if you [ __ ] me
man you didn't let me make it this far I
start rushing through the bit Yeah I
start my closer is a long closer yeah
man that's right
like an auction name I'm spinning it out
Kelly it got to a point it got to a
point where I said there's no way that I
can make I if I take a step it's going
to happen and I made a decision and I
was I remember looking these people in
the face
I looked these people this is these
people I looked these people in the face
I said [ __ ] it and I just I I had like a
little trench coat on and I wrapped it
around my waist and after I wrapped
around my waist I said
I said there it is and I I finished the
show and I was like good night I walked
off that stage he's telling me you said
deuces
[Laughter]
Deuces I walked off that stage I was
curious like good show man I said thanks
he said what is what is that you farted
I said that's [ __ ] give me to the
bathroom man hey I left I left those
jeans until this day I know that
somebody that night came across those
jeans in the trash yes I had my the
jeans yeah I walked out with just a
jacket around my waist no pants no draws
wow and I want to put some sweatpants on
and I said let's go I was almost there
but that didn't happen I ran off you ran
off well here's the difference did you
close I no and let me tell you what I
did I didn't run off I was very like
professional about it I was like
and it was during like a little
interlude of the song where the band was
kind of playing anyway and I just kind
of like yeah
uh beads of sweat and just kind of like
walked off and then was just like dead
actually to the to the nearest actually
Germany was a bathroom and and yeah my
my makeup artist ran down she was making
my hair on the road and she came and she
goes what's the oh my God
I was I got sick like you can't like
what do you do
[Music]
oh
foreign